it's it's it is interesting how we
perceive ourselves and do you think
that's based on your because mine's
based on my dad's interaction with me as
a kid yeah my dad no I was never be
right I'll never like I was the fastest
kid in first grade and I came home I
told my dad I'm a fast guy in first
grade and he said you'll never be faster
than me oh man yeah but not but this
wasn't he wasn't being a dick he was
just being a dad in the 80s or 70s and
so I went to the front yard at I don't
know I'm pretty quick let's race so we
got the front yard yeah this is like
childhood confidence that Mickey Mantle
team we're talking about and I split up
and I start counting down we sprint I'm
hauling ass and I look up and he's
running in front of me backwards going
you'll never beat me at anything
oh my that happened in every sport I
ever played with him but it was like a
way of going like I've got the big dick
this is how this works on the alpha and
so part of me has always looked for like
a father figure I think I do that in
agents and managers sometimes I got
father figure yeah and and and also it's
a way that I like kind of beat myself up
where I go like oh that was [ __ ]
horrible yeah you know yeah do you think
that was well I mean my dad doesn't
here's I mean it's similar in the way
that like when I went to go when I did
Jay Leno I did stand-up on Jay Leno and
he I told him no and to watch it and
then the next day he called me goes how
much did you pay them to get on that
like he thought that I saved up some
money are you saying how that's how
people get on The Tonight Show like Tom
Cruise goes on and goes here's the Koran
thanks for having me on you know Ben
thank you so much yeah like he you know
he thinks that this is easy or like this
is is this a real job I think now he's a
little better about it you know he's
proud but in the beginning dude it was
like you know how much are you paying
them or do they you don't get money
right and you're like yeah I make a lot
of money yeah and he's like you know be
like it's that guy so when you got mad
TV and and that's a one of those game
changers where you get I was
big guy on your mind he didn't he was I
mean it's not a game-changer it is I
mean you know you I would people say
that and I guess in retrospect maybe it
is but the thing is is at the time you
know you get like five grand a week dude
I remember when I got five grand a week
my first TV show and I did the math
wrong and I looked at my buddy Eddie in
the front seat we were on the corner of
Gower and Franklin and I went I'm a
[ __ ] millionaire not Korean math
there's a lot of money but if if you you
your agent and your manager 20% write
their taxes yeah so you're making about
$2,200 a week that you pocket it's good
if you can't buy a house but you can't
buy a house and it's not a life changer
you know when you growing up as a kid
when people said when you thought of a
TV star you go oh yeah he's you know
limos and mansion and his life you know
and that's wasn't the case um in fact
the new MADtv that happened last year I
know a couple of cast members that were
like oh no I'm still awake tables like
they're waiting tables really and still
on a show you know so you know the ones
like Eric Stonestreet you know that
we've had on our podcast people that
he's on Modern Family large gay men they
large gay men on my oh yeah yeah he's a
friend of ours and he makes a lot of
money but that show was a hit yeah if
you're a regular shows gonna be a hit
what the new one the new one's gonna be
it the new one dude the new one is got I
love the the female lead is from the
office right yeah she's awesome and
that's the role I always wanted to see
her in I'm no disrespect to the office
but I always wanted to see her in that
role that dude is [ __ ] awesome all it
was great it looks like it looks like a
it's gonna be a hit show and then you go
well the numbers are good
has it aired yet yet twice oh hell yeah
I always want to I want to take the time
yeah yeah I want to take the time to
thank Tiger belly fans because um we did
you guys were relentless especially
social media and whatnot we're very well
at the hash tagging all that stuff and I
like some good news it's not picked up
yet but um you know we wanted we won the
we won the timeslot
two weeks in a row and the numbers are
really good and you know the one thing
about the show that if I'm gonna say
anything about it's perfect
the showrunner is the actors I have a
great time on it it's hard for me to
figure out how to become me on that show
to do what I actually do I might not be
able to do that you know how like you
know how funny you can be yeah right and
then if you get a part where it's like
yeah I got a play so you're in this part
and there's not much you can do outside
of that you got to respect what the
writers exactly know I don't want to
misrepresent ya how they see the picture
that's it's their project yeah is there
money yeah so I can't go out and go
crazy I mean it's them but you know what
at the end of the day you know I'm happy
to you know be in it and
[Music]